ambiance apaisante nous sommes dans les
bureaux de l'agence marketing Clark
influence
on crée ici des publicités en
partenariat avec des influenceurs web
l'équipe est jeune branchée
archiver mais c'est sur l'utilisation du
bon vieux courrier électronique que doit
aber la directrice du développement
depuis que les serveurs ont atteint leur
pleine
capacités drive sont pleins les boîtes
mails sont pleines
étaient devenus trop volumineux ce qui a
poussé à une julie a donné des
formations pour éviter que les courriels
nuisent à la productivité moi quand je
suis concentré sur quelque chose je sais
que si j'ai un pop-up qui va arriver
mais tu te déconseilles puis te remettre
dedans ça te prend 10 minutes donc au
final va être plus du tout effet
efficace comme tu pourrais l'être selon
ce chercheur les travailleurs reçoivent
en moyenne 70 courriels par jour et on
envoie une quarantaine la plupart des
études arrivent à la conclusion que
quand c'est pas bien géré c'est un frein
à la productivité plus du quart de
l'emploi du temps serait alloué au
traitement des courriels une perte de
performance qui a un prix de
perturbations numériques de façon
générale sont estimées à environ en
moyenne entre 5000 et 10000 par employés
par année
amine travaille à partir d'un café de
retour d'une fin de semaine il compte
180 messages non lus c'est sûr que des
fois
qu'on accumule ça peut paraître
insémontable
pour y arriver il réserve de 3 à 4 blocs
de 4 heures dans sa semaine consacrée
exclusivement à la gestion de sa boîte
de réception en formant tout puissant
sur tes courriels ça te permet de te
mettre dans une genre de bulle puis de
dire ok c'est ça le travail que je vais
faire et le plaisir c'est de commencer
puis il y a un autre période qui arrive
l'autre système sur le prochain le talon
d'Achille du courriel c'est quand il
devient omniprésent notre attention se
fragmente en deux tâches une tâche on
revient une tâche en revient et en
étudiant le courriel on s'est rendu
compte que c'était une machine attention
fragmentée le cerveau humain a ses
limites une fois perturbé il faut en
moyenne 23 minutes pour regagner sa
pleine concentration et la cause
première de la surcharge mentale les
gens pensent que c'est lament seulement
de travail qu'ils ont c'est la tension
fragmentée parce que ça demande une
attention au cerveau qui est incapable
de générer
le secret d'Anne Julie trier son
courrier électronique avant de quitter
le bureau
de l'éducation si on dit jamais traité
des emails tu le fais pas puissent pas
enfin personne te le dis tu le sais pas
qu'il faut le faire mieux vaut donc il
courriel parce qu'il est après tout
incontournable ici Jean-Philippe
Radio-Canada Montréal